c'est l'artiste français le plus vendu
dans le monde depuis 2015 richard en
lenski merci d'être d'être là on se
tutoie en mouvement c'est quoi on se
tutoie fait plus allez on se tutoie
c'est plus simple voilà c'est là on est
on n'a pas de lien de parenté mais voir
les oeuvres de richard dans sa dans sa
galerie parce que vous le connaissez
c'est un sculpteur célèbre île l'île et
il est adulé par beaucoup beaucoup de
monde qui se voient là le fameux kong le
fameux king kong là qu'on voit partout
et bien c'est lui et on voit pas venir
aujourd'hui pour parler de sculptures
mais pour votre premier amour votre
nouveau projet tête de kong tête de
conques c'est votre premier pardon c'est
ton premier one man show ton premier one
man show en fait tu va nous raconter ton
histoire une histoire qui est assez
atypique et ensuite tu vas partir
sillonner les routes de france tout au
long de l'année 2019 et tu termineras
pour le spectacle le 17 juin prochain à
l'olympia
exactement c'est tout dit bon alors là
c'est toujours difficile d'avoir
plusieurs casquettes en france on le
sait on est au chanteur ou aux
sculpteurs ou comédiens etc
on croit peu aux gens qui ont peur de
multiples talents de multi casquettes
pourquoi est ce que tu te mets en danger
avec ce spectacle one man show pourquoi
entre guillemets te contente pas de ces
sculptures qui sont connus dans le monde
entier maintenant et bien c'est simple
en fait d'avancé vrai qu'en france on
accepte pas du tout les
d'avoir des dettes dans des cases c'est
de sortir des cases parce que ça se fait
pas ça marche beaucoup mieux dans des
pays comme aux états unis par exemple
mais j'avais déjà fait ça puisque déjà
ma sculpture j'étais pas accepter à la
base louis jacques est ce que je connais
depuis longtemps
gr j'ai écrit un livre a pas longtemps
et ça peut être pourquoi j'ai cassé les
codes
on rappelle qu'au départ tout à fait
plein plein plein de petits globes
agents immobiliers plein de choses comme
ça et puis un jour dans son garage tu as
commencé à faire de la sculpture
tu allais tu es allé démarcher notamment
des hôtels en disant prenez mes
sculptures dans les halls d'hôtels et
puis peut-être que ce sera repéré ce que
je fais mon travail et c'est sharon
stone quitte à repérer c'est sharon sont
effectivement festival de cannes elle
faisait un dîner où elle lever des fonds
pour un fonds de résine pour je ne sais
plus trop quoi c'est quand même un ouais
c'est vrai on a mis les cds sculpture
sur ses tables et to pitch été une belle
aventure mais mais se mettre en danger
pour répondre à ta question
c'est pas vraiment se mettre en danger
c'est que j'avais envie de transmettre
quelque chose et surtout pas le rapport
avec le public
j'ai un vrai pas moi c'est le partage
qui m'intéresse c'est pour ça que je
fais aussi de l'art populaire jeu
critiqué pour ça aussi parce que je fais
de l'art accessible à tous et ça gêne
beaucoup dans le petit milieu où sous
tend le parisianisme et dans ce
spectacle d'abord je parle de l'histoire
de l'art aussi donc je raconte des âges
j'essaie de d'apprendre des choses de
manière humoristique puisque bon j'ai un
collègue
oui parce que laurent baffie on parle de
l'holographie tu y participes arfa qui a
travaillé à la beaucoup travailler
exactement et donc du coup c'est essayer
de faire quelque chose de d'intelligent
et drôle en même temps et que et de
vendre partager avec le plus grand
nombre et moi ce qui m'intéresse et puis
la scène j'en ai fais parce que je veux
la musique aussi
ça aussi c'est aussi une manière de
casser les codes mais le rapport
vraiment avec le public c'est quelque
chose de génial
alors ils ont énormément de questions
bien évidemment à poser damien vous avez
vécu une enfance difficile en compagnie
d'un père violent à loyer lorsque l'on
est à faire pleurer dans les chaumières
alors pas du tout mais c'est important
de savoir d'où vous venez aussi parce
que lorsque l'on grandit dans cette
atmosphère de terreur comment on fait
justement pour s'en sortir comme vous
l'avez fait vous j'ai compris très tôt
que je pouvais compter que sur moi mais
en faite donc c'était c'est vrai c'était
assez compliqué c'était de la violence
qui était en vermois motion vers ma mère
donc c'était quelque chose d'assez
particulier quand mon père est parti
cela comme une délivrance
mais j'étais livré à moi-même et donc je
me suis dis bah on avait
on n'avait pas de sous on pourrait tout
à fait tout à fait clair ans c'était moi
c'étaient des amis qui se raconte oui
yves rossy qui me plaît le mcdo la frite
et la place de cinéma causé ces a donné
cette force de caractère aussi ce type
mais je remercie aujourd'hui moi en fait
je remercie mon père parce que j'aurais
pas eu ça peut être que chance à pas là
aujourd'hui je rappelle cette volonté
aujourd'hui et propose en font
aujourd'hui ils sont moins motivés quoi
je l'iran nous on avait une motivation
j'avais la rage la haine de faire
quelque chose et et c'était pas une
j'avais pas de jalousie quand je vois
des gens qui réussissent à égaliser ça
me donnait envie de faire comme eux donc
j'avais 7 7 7 dans des numéros il faut
que jerry faut que je m'en sorte mais
j'ai compris très très très tôt que
personne n'oserait donc c'est ça qui m'a
qu'il fallait y aller tout cela donc
finalement jean tirer quelque chose de
positif alors caroline si on reparle de
ce que vous faites dans le milieu de
l'art contemporain qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui vous disent que vous
êtes un opportuniste que tout ça est
beaucoup trop facile et que voilà en
fait ces fameuses art populaire qu'est
ce que vous voulez que je l'aurais point
moi et moi je vais vous expliquer j'ai
quand il ya quand je fais quelque chose
à 90 personnes qui sont contents disent
qu'ils sont pas contentes mal ratio me
convient tout à fait c'est pas un
problème
moi ce qui est ce que j'aime c'est
parler au plus grand nombre encore une
fois ce que disait partager faire de
l'art accessible facile il ya d'autres
sculpteurs en leur temps comme ça
françois pompon ont été critiqués parce
qu'il simplifier les formes marque c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué de les faire
moyen de l'émotion les enfants ça plaît
aux enfants ça paie à tout le monde
voilà me cherche pas vous dites que vous
êtes un peu comme le andy warhol 2.0
c'est à dire qu'andy warhol il faisait
des destinées de lait soupes et vous
leur dites moi je dessine aussi et j'en
passe je fais de la sculpture c'est si
je suis pas su prétentieux quand même
comparé à andy warhol mais disons que
andy warhol fait c'est vrai que pour moi
c'est vrai que c'est cette démarche là
oui c'est une démarche et puis c'est un
c pour ça un dieu sait qu'elle a créé
quelque chose qui invente quelque chose
qui est génial fectivement de rendre
l'art populaire pour tous que tout que
un quidam j'ai fait une collaboration
avec disney on vend des sculptures
signées chance qui à 49 euros
donc je vire ça ça m'a valu les
critiques sur ce soit accessible à tous
thibault laurent baffie met en scène
donc votre spectacle
on le connaît bien ici sur ces 8 laurent
ça veut dire que vous nous promettez
d'être trash impertinence politiquement
incorrect sexy sur scène comment ça va
être ma fille j'ai commencé une petite
partie du sport
ja pertinent non pas du tout laurent et
moi c'est bon c'est une histoire d'amour
c'est qui on a une rencontre c'est
quelque chose de bien dans le bon sens
du terme
mais non c'est quelque chose on a
vraiment travaillé sur quelque chose qui
était pour qui sonne à ma bouche que je
suis ce que je suis s'interpréter qui
maillent je ne pourrais pas et semble
qui me ressemble absolument pas sortir
ce que saint laurent mais devant ça
passerait pas ça marcherait pas ça
marche que laurence qui dit ça marche
que chez lui et laurent nader n'a jamais
écrit pour les autres pratiquement et a
dû écrire un petit peu oubliée avons
obéi au début mais il n'a jamais voulu
écrire aux personnes et donc c'est cette
histoire
hilali s'est beaucoup intéressé à
l'histoire de l'art c'est ce qui l'a
beaucoup touché quelque part c'est un
échange et et il s'est mis un petit peu
à ma place donc c'est donc ce sera pas
mais ça sera très très drôle
c'est très drôle mais on apprend des
choses en fait c'est très drôle on
apprend des choses mais il rappelle moi
il y aura des petits trucs forcément
faut pas avoir peur manière voir donc si
je m'amuse à léo termine avec tatiana
t'il possible par hasard dans un avenir
plus ou moins proche que vous ayez
l'idée de sculpter le corps d'une femme
cependant je pourrais vous proposer
d'être votre moule votre moule
non vous pourriez éventuellement être
m'amuse dans ces cas là donc c'est bon
dieu savait grand pelé c'est ma
prochaine bah voilà on nous appelait pad
mais justement
et ben voilà china devient la muse de
richard hall inscrits alors ça c'est la
peau une première sur le plateau de c
que de la télé
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup richard et donc je
rappelle le nouveau projet tête de kong
et on pourra vous retrouvez tout au long
de l'année 2019 sur toutes les routes de
france et sa terrier et le 17 juin
prochain à l'olympia
[Applaudissements]